hello everyone my name is swan producer
at blue12 studio
and today i'm going to show you more
about stray
[Music]
[Music]
in stray you play as a cat who has
fallen inside the mysterious and
forgotten city
separated from his family and injured he
will have to explore and survive in this
unwelcoming environment
[Music]
from the cat's unique point of view
players must navigate their way through
the dangers of this unfriendly place
and use the cat's skills to solve
puzzles and uncover mysteries along the
[Music]
way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
along his journey the cat will meet a
small drone named b12
[Music]
using the drone's ability to interact
with objects in the world
and communicate with the strange
inhabitants of this secluded place
together they will work to learn more
about the secrets of this forgotten
community
of human-like machines
[Music]
what
[Music]
of course the cat will always be a cat
and his adventures will be filled with
friendly and playful interactions with
his new world
but these machines are not the only
inhabitants of the city
and some encounters will not be as
[Music]
friendly
[Music]
running fast jumping and using spells to
avoid dangers
will all be vital if you want to escape
this city and be reunited with family
[Music]
[Music]
unless you find a way to defend yourself
and the prey might become the hunter
stray is coming to ps4 ps5 as well as pc
in early 2022 and we can't wait to show
you more
[Music]